you know let's talk about this this
project that you're working on with
Warren Buffett millionaires club aims to
offer some pretty practical financial
advice to kids something that it seems
this country is very much in need of
right well it's called the secret
Millionaire's Club and as you said it's
about offering advice but at the same
time it's telling stories that are kid
relatable stories Warren plays himself
in animation he's kind of a Socratic
mentor to a group of kids who have all
kinds of adventures in business ranging
from the lemonade stand to anything you
could possibly imagine and they learn
lessons through Warren's informed
tutelage it has high jinks and comedy in
crisis and jeopardy and stakes and all
the pieces of good storytelling that you
expect it's great i've often wondered
why we don't have you know home
economics where I grew up it was
basically learning to make chocolate
chip cookies and sew on a button and
I've always said why isn't there a place
for sort of real home economics yeah I
in the classroom this is a way to make
real economics home economics and
business fun for kids right well we are
not trying to teach kids how to read a
balance sheet or anything like that they
are lessons that will teach kids how to
succeed in business but more importantly
how to succeed in life they're really
fundamental values that are values that
Warren espouses and lives so how
involved was he in this project with you
Warren has been in hands-on from day one
he gave us a curriculum which we put
into the series based on all of his
teachings and the things that he does we
he does his own voices he reads every
script that's great he gives no ton of
script i should add he's a one-take guy
the lines come out perfect every time we
rarely ask him to repeat a line because
we couldn't ask for them to come out any
better great and warren hosts a
an event at the end of each year where
kids have submitted ideas for their own
businesses and we bring the finalists to
Omaha and we have a luncheon with Warren
where they get to show him his business
ideas